dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jonah a fair-weather
a technique can be deemed as artificial
intelligence or not is a question that I
would like to see exiled from future
debates and argumentations of course
anyone may take part in any debate of
their liking I would however like to
point out the futility of such endeavors
let me explain why ever heard a parent
and the son having an argument whether
the son is an adult or not you are not
an adult because adults don't behave
like this and arguments like that the
argument is not really about whether a
person is an adult but it is about the
very definition of an adult do we define
an adult as someone who has common sense
and behaves responsibly or is it enough
to be of eighteen or twenty-one years
old to be an adult if we decide which
definition we go for the scaffolding for
the entire argument crumbles because it
is built upon a term for which the
definition is not agreed upon I feel
that we have it the same with artificial
intelligence in many debates the
definition of artificial intelligence or
at least one possible definition is the
following
artificial intelligence is the
intelligence exhibited by machines or
software it is a bit of a cop-out so we
have to go and check the definition of
intelligence there are multiple
definitions but for the sake of argument
we are going to let this one slip one
possible definition for intelligence is
the ability to learn or understand
things or to deal with new or difficult
situations now this sentence is teeming
with ill-defined terms such as learn
understand things deal with new
situations difficult situations so if we
have a shaky definition of artificial
intelligence it is quite possibly
pointless to argue whether self-driving
cars can be deemed artificially
intelligent or not imagine two
physicists arguing whether a material is
ferromagnetic but none of them has the
slightest idea what magnetism means if
we look at it like this it is very easy
to see the futility of such arguments if
we had as poorly crafted definitions in
physics as we have for intelligence
magnetism would be defined as
stuff pulling on other stuff this is the
first part of the argument the second
part is that artificial intelligence is
imagined to be a mystical thing that
only exists in the future or it may
exist in the present but it has to be
shrouded in mystery let me give you an
example the a-star algorithm used to be
called AI and was and still is widely
taught in AI courses at many
universities a-star is used in many
pathfinding situations where we seek to
go from A to B on a map in the presence
of possible obstacles it is widely used
in robotics and computer games nowadays
calling a path finding algorithm AI is
simply preposterous
it is a simple well understood technique
that does something we are used to
imagine someone waving their GPS device
claiming that there is AI in there but
back then when it was new
hazy and poorly understood we put it in
a drawer with the label AI on it as soon
as people start to understand it they
pull it out from this drawer and
disgustedly claim well this is not AI is
just a graph algorithm graphs are not AI
that's just a thematics it is important
to note that none of the techniques that
we see today are mysterious in any sense
the entirety of deep learning and
everything else is a series of carefully
prescribed mathematical operations I
will try to briefly assess the two
arguments arguments about AI are not
about the algorithms they seem to be
discussing but about the very definition
of AI which is ill-defined at best
AI is imagined to be a mystical thing
that only exists in the future or it may
exist in the present but it has to be in
some way shrouded in mystery the good
news is that using this knowledge we can
easily diffuse such futile arguments if
someone says that deep learning is not
artificial intelligence because all it
does is matrix algebra we can ask okay
what is your definition of artificial
intelligence if this person defines AI
as being a sentient learning being akin
to humans then we have immediately
arrived to a conclusion that deep
learning is not AI let us not fool
ourselves by thinking that we are
arguing
about things when we are simply arguing
about definitions as soon as the
definition is agreed upon the conclusion
emerges effortlessly thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time